humanity is running down a with
this AI business
I'm not saying that AI isn't useful it's
useful but if we start replacing human
interaction with AI we're in deep deep
I'm not concerned about AI being
involved in the manufacturing of
whatever right I'm concerned about AI
being involved in the decision-making
processes
that have life weighing in the balance
so if we are taking in stories that have
been made better by these digital
Wizards then we're going to lose a lot
of what was Humane because we're not
here to make faster cars we're not here
to make more beautiful televisions we're
here to evolve our consciousness
so that we can graduate into a higher
existence